good morning John good news for a
self-employed people with chronic
pre-existing conditions like myself soon
insurance companies will not be able to
be biased against you for having even
the bazzara stuff pre-existing
conditions today I wanted to bring you
the top 10 weirdest diseases that I
could find on the Internet in no
particular order the first bizarre
disease that I want to talk about today
is complications due to lightning strike
those who have been struck often have
problems with their memory with their
equilibrium with motor control and oddly
enough are much much more likely to
commit suicide than the average person
however this is by far the most peculiar
bit one of the complications of being
struck by lightning is that you are much
more likely to be struck by lightning
again so yeah if for example the place
that lightning does not strike twice is
Roy Sullivan that is inaccurate because
Roy Sullivan was struck by lightning
seven times
bizarre disease number two is pica a
disease common in children but also
oddly enough common in pregnant women in
which people want to eat things that are
not food you got nails dirt coal sand
pounds and pounds of human hair stolen
from beauty salons bizarre disease
number three then tendonitis min
tendonitis is exactly what it sounds
like it's any repetitive stress injury
caused by video gaming
relatedly joggers nipple is a common
disease and joggers in which their tight
shirts rub against their nipples and
then they create nipple fissures joggers
nipple just one more reason why I love
to fit bizarre disease number four odd
skin coloration some people are black
some people are white some people are
all the way in between but some people
are blue or red for example if there's a
lot of silver in your diet say that you
live in a place where there's tons of
silver in the water or you have silver
related Pike up your skin will turn blue
disease number five Toxoplasma is a
parasite that lives in cat poop the
really strange thing is here that women
with toxoplasmosis are statistically
happier than women who do not have it
while men have more negative side
effects to toxoplasmosis and thus it has
been posited that toxoplasmosis is the
reason why there are so many crazy old
cat ladies and not so many crazy old cat
men next bizarre disease
sensitivity to pain might sound like a
pretty good thing you're certainly not
gonna lose any fistfights but people who
suffer from congenital analgesia
generally have very short lifespans
because they don't know when they're
being injured or when they're
uncomfortable children with this disease
sometimes bite through their lips or
tongue and often cause severe damage to
their eyes without even knowing it
Nutmeg psychosis is psychosis caused by
nutmeg nutmeg taken in significant
enough quantities can cause paranoia
hallucinations feelings of impending
doom now we've all got body odor there's
no need to deny and tell me that your
armpits smell like flowers but you
probably don't have body odor like the
people who suffer from triethylamine
Ariha some people don't have the enzyme
needed to break down triethylamine and
so triethylamine buildup in their bodies
and you can smell it in their breath and
their sweat and their pee unfortunately
for them try a philomene smells kind of
like rotting fish so that's what they
smell like which is pretty horrible and
finally number 10 we have possibly the
coolest name in all of medical disorder
history Ondine's curse Ondine's curse
aside from being a really horrible curse
is fascinating because people who suffer
from it literally die if they fall
asleep you're either born with it or it
sets in after a serious trauma and it's
more officially called primary alveolar
hypoventilation but the name of the
disease comes from the myth of Undine
who in greek mythology is a man who
cheated on a water nymph which let me
tell you is something you never want to
do the water nymph was so enraged that
she cursed him to forget to breathe if
he ever fell asleep John the theme for
this week is top 10 list that was mine I
want to hear if you guys have any
bizarre diseases in the comments telling
me about all the diseases that you have
and tell me how you're feeling about the
new healthcare legislation I'm looking
forward to seeing all of you in the
comments John I will see you on
Wednesday don't forget to be awesome